foreign
[Music]
guys here we are once again doing
another book review
so any of you guys that have been around
here for any length of time at all
uh we'll know that I absolutely love
Grady Hendricks very prolific author uh
I've read and reviewed a bunch of his
books on here um horror store my best
friend's exorcism uh Southern book
club's guide to slaying vampires and the
final girls support group
um you know I've also read his
non-fiction book which I really
recommend which is called paperbacks
from hell I didn't review that one
because I usually just do fiction on
here but that is a really awesome book
too but I was kind of browsing through
books a million the other day
and I came across one of his books that
I hadn't read and that I also don't hear
as many people talking about as maybe
they talk about some of his other ones
uh this was actually his 2018 novel
which is called we sold our souls now
because the premise of this one involves
music like a deal with the devil kind of
and sort of like tangentially the whole
like satanic Panic era kind of thing
um this kind of seemed right up my alley
so I was like yeah I'm totally gonna buy
this and read it now I will say that
um this book like all of Grady
hendricks's books like pretty much rules
um all of his books rule
um I think I connected with it slightly
less than some of the other ones but
like I said that's really not saying all
that much that's really not that much of
a criticism because all his books are so
good that you know this one I I think I
connected slightly less but it was just
like a little fraction of like a thing
so it's like don't take that as like too
much of a criticism uh because I still
really I mean I adored this book just
like most of his other ones and I would
totally recommend it to anybody who you
know likes hendrix's stuff in general
and especially people that are also like
really into heavy metal or any kind of
like musical subgenre like that now I
probably mentioned this before in some
of my other reviews
um of his stuff but Grady Hendricks is
actually really good at writing very
compelling female lead characters which
is something that uh you know like a lot
of male authors are not really that good
at or not really like all that known for
um and honestly this novel is no
exception so our main protagonist is a
young woman named Chris Pulaski and
she's kind of like this working class
heavy metal guitarist who kind of at you
know at one time was sort of like maybe
poised on the edge of stardom like her
band which is called uh dirt work but
with use with umlauts you know what I
mean like because it's heavy metal
um they were actually gonna open for
Slayer like back in the 90s so they were
just right on the cusp of being super
famous
however uh at the after that it kind of
all went horribly wrong
so nowadays Chris is in her 40s uh and
she's still kind of stuck in this just
real like dead end meth adult town that
she grew up in uh she still lives in her
parents kind of disintegrating house her
parents are dead I believe but she still
lives in the house and the neighborhood
they live in which used to be kind of
like a nice working middle class
neighborhood it's kind of like slowly
been going to seed uh you know what I
mean so she's kind of like the only
person left like pretty much from from
back in that day uh she still drives her
dad's old 20 year old like hand-me-down
car uh you know is drowning in credit
card debt and she works night shifts at
this kind of like crappy Best Western
hotel and one of the things that she
deals with all the time is this guy that
lives in the hotel and he just like
always comes out and like rants at her
and like pees on the front desk and [__]
like that so obviously her life has
taken a turn let's put it that way and
she hasn't really done anything creative
like in a really long time like she
hasn't picked up a Guitar she hasn't
written a song like she's kind of put
her guitar away and hasn't done anything
like that
Now by contrast her former bandmate from
dirt work whose name is Terry hunt who
is the singer he is actually one of the
most successful musicians the world has
ever seen he actually formed a band
called coffin with a K and he operates
under the kind of guys of uh figure like
a character called The Blind King
now Terry has more money and more power
than Chris can even imagine
uh Chris is actually pretty bitter about
Terry's success and has been for quite a
long time and not least of which not not
just because of sour grapes but because
she believes pretty much that Terry kind
of like ditched the band back in the day
when they were just right on the cusp of
becoming famous and basically like stole
all her music and like all her ideas and
like used that as a jumping off point to
be like super famous himself
but um it seems like she's kind of like
oh well whatever she's still kind of mad
about her she's not really doing
anything about it but at the beginning
of the story
her uh Fury about this whole situation
gets compounded because she starts
seeing Billboards everywhere and like
radio ads and things like that and that
are kind of plugging coffins big
farewell tour and it's gonna be like the
musical event of the century so she's
just kind of like hmm well that's not
good is it now because she's like I said
in kind of like a dead end miserable
life and it's just going nowhere so
Chris decides at this juncture because
she's reminded of all of that again that
she's gonna get to the bottom of what
happened with her former band back in
the 90s and how she sort of like ended
up in this predicament that she's in
see what happened was back in the 1990s
like not long after like almost
immediately after the Slayer gig
Terry the singer and the manager of dirt
work his name was what was his name Rob
I think was his name they presented the
band members uh which was Chris a guy
named tuck a guy named Bill and a guy
named Scotty rocket and they presented
them with what seemed like kind of
lucrative contracts right problem was
the contracts were essentially asking
the members of dirt work to give up all
of the rights to the band and to their
music to Terry like exclusively now he
was going to give each of them like a
big Hefty fee but he was essentially
going to be like well you guys can't uh
you know pretty much do anything anymore
you don't have the rights to the band
you don't have the rights into the music
you wrote you don't have any of that
kind of stuff
now all the other guys in the band um
they were pissed off about this but they
sort of like were grudgingly open to
these terms because it was a lot of
money that he was offering but Chris was
absolutely livid I mean she pretty much
accused Terry of selling out and of
betraying them and she just absolutely
refused to go along with his whole
scheme however from this fateful
occasion uh which all the band members
just refer to as contract night with
capital letters Chris has a really big
gap in her memory like after she
basically said I'm not signing that and
stormed out of the house there's like a
four hour period where she can't
remember anything like she can't
remember what happened after that
um and actually neither none of the
other guys can actually remember what
happened that night either
but Chris suspects that whatever it was
that occurred in this in these missing
hours
um it was kind of like the beginning of
the downward spiral that just ended up
like sucking her and her bandmates down
and also kind of like the start of
Terry's you know meteoric rise to Mega
stardom now these were like parallel
events that Chris knows are linked
somehow but she doesn't know exactly how
so after that whole premise and the
history of this of that is like
established
um the book kind of becomes something
like a road trip sort of story because
Chris pretty much like abandons her lame
life and sort of attempts to reconnect
with her former bandmates and she's
trying to convince them to come with her
to confront Terry at his big final show
in Las Vegas like he's having this big
he's hosting like this big festival with
like all these other bands and stuff
like that like out in the desert and so
she's trying to get all her other
bandmates to come out and like figure
out like get to the bottom of it and
confront him and see if if they can sort
some [__] out you know what I mean and
find out what exactly it was that
happened on contract night and why they
can't remember any of it now this is
kind of harder than it sounds because
the other guys from dirt work actually
kind of hate her because they sort of
just see her as this Troublemaker who
refused to go along with the whole
sellout and so they still um are kind of
bitter about her like you know messing
up their gig or whatever and so she
pretty much has like an upward climb
when she tries to contact them again
because a lot of them don't want to see
her and what's even worse than that is
that as as the events of the book unfold
it starts to become very obvious that
something
Supernatural uh evil and really like
far-reaching and kind of far beyond
human understanding is going on behind
this entire ugly Affair you know what I
mean so along the way Chris ends up
having to tap back into her like
Creative Energy I guess like to battle
these overwhelming forces that she's
encountering and of particular
significance in that regard is this
concept album called troglodyte that she
wrote back in the day
and she wrote it and she thought it was
their best stuff but then Terry and the
manager back in the 90s wouldn't allow
the band to release it uh for reasons
which are eventually unveiled now as a
sideline there's also like another minor
character whose name is Melanie and
she's actually a coffin fan and she's
trying to get across the country to see
the show in Vegas so she only turns up
kind of near the beginning of the story
and then toward the end but she almost
kind of serves not just like as a
bookend character but something is like
a little bit of a mirror to Chris's
character in a way because she's like
another young woman that's trying to
make her way like in the very male
dominated uh metal scene but she's kind
of like more of an appreciator like
coming at it from the fan uh perspective
whereas Chris is actually like a Creator
who you know essentially had her best
ideas like ripped off and undermined by
a dude who just wanted money and fame
and didn't really care who he [__]
over to get it so like I said I mean
like all of Grady hendricks's books all
of which I have just loved unreservedly
uh this one is also it's just it's just
a blast it's fun it's gory and just the
whole thing is is great uh it's also
like a lot of his stuff just very
genuinely heartfelt and I think in
particular this will resonate really
hard with anybody that's into any kind
of musical sub-genre like you know is
really uh hardcore into any kind of
musical sub-genre like and anyone who's
ever felt like whatever kind of music
they're into has like really pulled them
through difficult times or saved their
lives or something like that this is
very much I mean he very much takes
heavy metal like or or any kind of like
sub-genre or music that you know saves
your life or something like that he
takes that very very seriously and I
really liked that also and this is kind
of like a little bit of stuff that's
kind of going on underneath but I think
this is also kind of a little bit of a
subtle exploration of some of the
struggles of poverty maybe and like how
easy it is to essentially parcel out
tiny portions of your soul just to get
by or just to obtain you know Comforts
or luxuries uh until one day you know
when you're much older you find that
your entire soul like meaning your
passion or your dream or your ultimate
goal for life or whatever
um is gone like you don't have it
anymore and then like the sad thing
about that is that you find like you
really don't give a [__] anymore that
it's gone you know what I mean
um and this is kind of like a heavy
concept but I think Grady Hendricks
always comes at things with such a light
touch that even though these themes are
there they don't really feel intrusive
or like he's shoehorning them in or
anything like that it's just something
that's kind of rumbling under the
surface that you can kind of like pick
up on or not as you feel like it so yeah
I mean we sold our souls pretty much has
anything you could ask for like in a
horror novel it's really entertaining
it's like epic in scale uh it's gross
it's funny uh it's badass like a lot of
the characters uh are really badass and
it has really great characters that you
actually really care about and it has
like a really Earnest
um you know Beating Heart at the center
of it and that makes the stakes of the
story seem like that much bigger let
that much more earth-shattering so I
think metal fans in particular will
probably love this but anybody who's
into like I said any kind of like
musical sub genre to any great degree
like that will probably really relate to
it hard because I certainly did
um and really anybody that just likes
really fast-paced road trip kind of
horror that has these sort of like big
conspiratorial like Sinister satanic
forces like as the antagonists I think
they should really dig it as well so
that will do it for this tomes of Terror
hope you guys enjoyed it please like
share subscribe and all of that other
kind of stuff and I will see you guys
again on the next one bye